[Music]
[Applause]
stat of the day brought to you by Panini
America the official trading cards to
the damn Patrick Show Tyler says he's
getting all kinds of phone calls that
people want to rate our
looks H you got to have a sense of humor
to work on this program Robert uh
emailed and said uh this rating is like
driving every one thinks they're above
average yeah all right that's fair
Melinda wrote in Dan she's got you as a
10 as women Dan is hot oh 50% is the
voice yeah uh she also rated Todd as a
two sry Todd wow 50% of that is also the
voice uh no she didn't she didn't say
that damn
damn okay but you know that fritzy is
going to have a terrible day the rest of
the day very sensitive okay and he's got
to go home too and be like you're not
that much hotter than me no
that's what he's going to say to his
wife that's what he's thinking I'm
actually going to be staring at myself
in the mirror for hours you're going to
go you're going to go to your wife and
you're going to go what would you rate
me H because if you look at Todd's
comments from before he wasn't upset
that uh like people were like wow your
wife is really good-looking it was that
she was so much better looking than him
and he's like I'm not that bad looking
I'm not that what the hell she's not
that much hotter than me yeah I made it
about me for a change and this is the
wrong guest to have on right after this
guy yeah markk Sanchez joining us on the
program yeah Mark how would you rate
yourself I'm obviously not Big E
wherever he's from my man who said a
truckload of it uh oh yeah I got that's
the truck driver from Indiana yeah one
of our callers I'm obviously not Big E
no no who is yeah um I don't know but
this is really funny and I feel bad for
fritzy man no don't no don't I got a
five and a two these are some of the
numbers we're throwing around yeah add
them together big guy right there you go
Mark's got my back all right uh so Mark
Sanchez Fox NFL analyst former NFL USC
quarterback here all right we asked this
question yesterday will Josh Allen win a
Super Bowl in his
career yes I I absolutely think so I
think
um I saw the whole debate yesterday with
orlovski with Ryan Clark with Rex I saw
it with Shannon and and all these guys
and this narrative that's coming out
like Josh didn't play well enough
yesterday or Sunday to win I I can't
subscribe to that I just can't I I I
think he played well enough to win look
at um you know I thought Ryan Clark made
a really good point um about when you go
get that gold jacket and when you give
your acceptance speech whatever like the
person presenting you doesn't have to
say much but everybody in the crowd when
they look at Tom Brady is going to
remember the Julian Edelman catch some
big kicks by veter some amazing throws
by Tom Brady amazing reads amazing
deliveries diving catches by
gronowski uh defensive stops and
interceptions that put him in a good
place and he took advantage of it yes
he's the trigger man yes he's the guy
and he's going to get all the blame and
all the praise and that's the way it
goes but this notion that Josh didn't
play well enough that's just crazy to me
I mean he played well enough to win
twice now and got LED down by the rest
of the team and he wore it just wore it
on the chin no problem and he wore it on
the chin early in the year when he
wasn't taking care of the football and
people said oh he's trying to be
Superman he needs to just chill and run
the system and then pick your spots to
make your big plays well that's what he
did and now he didn't play well enough
so that I I just don't like the the
double standard there and then somebody
made the point about um you know Patrick
Mahomes we wouldn't be saying this about
Patrick we'd be saying he didn't play
well that's not true we said his guys
been dropping the ball all year so that
one that one's I have a hard time
stomaching that I think he just he needs
a little help he's got a guy walked into
his lap his left tackle who's battling
in the game he gets walked into his lap
effects the throw three huge drop passes
uh and how about Cooks he uh cook he
makes up for the drop to cook that's a
walk-in touchdown yeah on the halfback
angle before halftime so he runs it in
himself like don't tell me Jos play what
come on man that's crazy um so I don't
know I I think he's a heck of a player I
think he's gonna be just fine they just
in those positions I mean they were
decimated at linebacker their defense
Kansas City walked the ball up at they
had five third Downs Dan five third
Downs are you kidding me yeah that's how
well they were moving the ball on first
and second down you don't even need
third down that's a quarterback's dream
that is like it's easy I I don't know
that's wild to me against a really good
defense so I don't know help me
understand the drama with the Cowboys
with CD lamb and Dak Prescott and
relatives are now involved in this that
it feels like CD's mom criticizing Dak
and dak's brother criticizing CD and uh
how do you how do you bring that you
know some closure so you already have
enough drama because you play for the
Cowboys but that that's bad that was
going to be my point that was going to
be my first point so that goes um oh man
it's not inherently good or bad this
this Spotlight that comes with being a
cowboy and wearing the star okay and
being the quarterback there ask Tony
Romo but it's like fire fire isn't
inherently good or bad it can warm you
it can cook your food and it can burn
down your whole damn Village so how do
you use this fire how do you use this
Spotlight how do you
um um how do you take advantage of it
and how do you handle the negative parts
of it and and create barriers or or
safety measures so that you don't get
burned by this white hot Spotlight well
the family on Twitter which is the you
know bathroom wall of the internet
anybody can say anything you know like
come on for a good time call Big E and
then put his phone number in there you
know what I mean like you can put
anything on there that's ridiculous so
now that the families are involved it's
just taking this to like this other
level of I mean do we need to all sit
down in the living room and not know why
they're there and then somebody walks in
and it's like we're all here because we
love each other yeah but but Kevin
Burkhart said there was something that
was tangible there was tension going on
in that game between these two you could
you could see it on TV it was so it was
like Dak had to force him the ball later
in the game and they got off to a weird
start um listen I've been there where
you're just off with a player and had
nothing to do with off the field stuff
but just you're off he went to 10 yards
I thought he was going to be at nine you
know uh based on The Leverage or
coverage or whatever I thought he was
gonna break at this route or whatever
this depth or this move or that showed
me this and we just kind of are off and
I'd literally go to the coordinator and
say hey just hand him the ball snap him
the ball give them put in the reverse to
him whatever throw him just a quick ball
just to get back in Rhythm you know what
I mean just let's just get on the same
page and then we'll figure out the rest
of it um and you know put one good dep
positive deposit in the in the bank it
it was just it really was tangible
palpable through the TV so I can only
imagine what it felt like at the game
yeah but it just looked off and now you
got family members like perpetuating
this thing it's just I don't understand
that I I know and the the point
is the good thing is the family cares
right they one the family's around two
they care so like let's say something
positive about it but three okay you got
to understand what these comments mean
to other people and how like it's hard
enough to win a game it's hard enough to
convert a third down to to get a scoring
Drive orchestrated but now you're gonna
you know throw shade at the guy trying
to give your kid the ball or your
like it just doesn't help anybody and
and it's really too bad you know it's
it's a good thing that that these
mediums and and um um you know forms of
media like exist for people to get their
talent out there and opinions out there
and there's some good stuff you can get
from it but also there's some negative
that comes with it too and it's it's
really too bad for that team to even
have to like how do you even start
talking about that all I want to do is
we just want to go win games you know
that stuff I don't got time for that if
you're Kansas City can you try to make
Lamar Jackson either a passer or a
runner like can you can you make you I
mean your goal is to make him
onedimensional I'm I'm guessing but it
doesn't really work but what would be
your mindset Kansas City's defense
approach he's gotten better as a passer
which is the problem for defenses and
even since his MVP year his MVP year was
much more of the scrambling the wow
plays the you know it looks like a
Madden football game because he's so
dang
talented now he's starting especially in
that second half last week he's starting
to get to a place where people never
knew he could get to meaning drop back
you know 10 to 15 times a game go
through your first couple reads and get
to three four and five with a quick
little pocket movement that that's the
NFL you know what I mean good teams good
defenses will force you to do that so in
my opinion the best you can keep the
clamps On The Run game and his he's
gonna get a couple right you're playing
Jordan you're playing LeBron you're
playing Kobe he's they're gonna get some
you got to do your best to just mitigate
that and try and take away one of his
best targets try and you know Force Mark
Andrews out of the game you know control
Z flowers pick one of them and make
somebody else beat you and then that
that's gonna be your formula to win
essentially if they do these things if
he drops back 15 times and gets to his
third read you know 12 of those times
and completes those balls on our
defense he deserves to win the game and
that's the way Chris Jones I need a play
I need one play you know what I mean uh
these guys up front tranquil who I love
McDuffy come on now this is your game
the second year dude I love he's allpro
as a nickel are you kidding me this
McDuffy kid is a baller man I love him
um you know like one of those guys you
got to make the game-changing play
without doing anything outside of our
system One's Gonna Come your way you got
to capitalize on it and and that's what
I would try and do force him to drop
back 15 times convert these third Downs
going long drives converting third Downs
on those multiple third Downs on those
drives with his arm and see if he can do
it and if he can do it he deserves a win
if the Bears called you and asked you
what to do with the number one overall
pick oh
boy you know what we we're gonna have to
do this one I need to go watch it and
and here's the other thing I mean you
see the USC stuff in my deal like that's
you know I love my school I love you
want to do this in a month do you want
to wait a month yeah because I gotta go
I gotta go really grind on these guys I
got to figure out like what um pause I
got to go grind on their film and uh
figure out who I would legitimately take
no no but you did pause you did pause
you did pause a while there so what
makes you nervous about Caleb
Williams no I I just because I don't
want to say yes I would go Caleb
Williams or I would go uh Drake May or I
would go anybody without really watching
I've been to two of Caleb Williams games
they were against San Jose State and
maybe Nevada so it's not a real okay
good would you move on from Justin
Fields would you move on from Justin
Fields once again formula to win could I
come up with a formula for him to win
heck yes it's going to be a lot more
designed runs it's going to be a little
more of the earlier Lamar Jackson stuff
until I can get him to a place where
he's going to be one of those not
necessarily he's never going to be a
pure dropback passer that's not a game
because you're kind of taking away his
Stinger if you do that to him I think
you can get him to a place and in a
system that has the proper structure to
where look at Kyler Murray towards the
end of the season he's not running
nearly as much Lamar Jackson not running
nearly as much um you know there's
players that you can that you can um
teach and mold uh look at Mahomes even I
mean that's a that's a structured system
and he learned from a dropback guy in
Alex Smith his first year and saw how it
happens now when it's time to move
around I mean there's nobody better and
you let him use his in instincts and and
go beat the other team and you're not
necessarily beating scheme at that point
you're beating players it's a player
beating a player not defeating a scheme
the scheme was right the defense had you
had you you know nailed down you're were
done there was there was nowhere to go
but you make a play and that's where you
kind of get over the hump with Justin
and just keep continuing to groom him
but once again that is arguably and I
played in New York that that might be
just tough if not tougher to play there
that is a rough media Market man they
are they are on you I mean it is um at
least New York you get a little bit of
of um deflection with Giants and jets
you got two teams there that can take a
little bit of of the blow for you but
Chicago man it's uh and they're starving
for for a winning team right now so it's
uh that's a tough place but yes in a
month I will have a full breakdown on
the qvs for you all right quickly Before
We Say Goodbye how does this weekend
play
out as much as I want the Lions to win
just just because of the story like the
memes about this game have you seen the
the Eminem rolling up in Eight Mile and
that's Jared GF rolling up to the game
with the lons like that one killed me
that one was so funny to me um I just
you know that's the Feelgood story
they're going on the road like that is a
tough group and and Dan Campbell said
this is what the team's gonna be and
everybody kind of laughed at him and
wrote them off and they're in a smaller
market so
whatever I mean can you imagine those
guys in the Super Bowl that place would
nut I me I mean the whole city of Las
Vegas is going to be all of
Detroit um so that I just don't know if
they can do it there I think the 49ers
the big thing for the ners they got a
they got a pressure go man where are
these guys up front the bossas the
armads the hard Graves you picked up uh
Randy Gregory you picked up uh Chase
young I mean that is a star studed cast
there like where's I need some
production out of those guys I need at
least three from you guys right like and
a couple tit balls Eric armstead's like
a redwood tree man he's massive so that
guy's got to affect the game they got to
shut down Gibbs I think Sam Fran has the
advantage um and then you know this is
the Year this is the year the bill
should have caught KC this is the year
that that Lamar Jackson's got to handle
his business at home once again he
played an excellent second half and you
could tell he took over that thing so I
could see Sam Fran and and Baltimore
handling this thing you never want to
bet against Mahomes and I might regret
it but uh if I got a pick I'll go Sam
Fran Baltimore great talk to you we'll
have you back in a month and then you
could tell us what you think Chicago
should do tell you who I'm drafting love
it all right that's Mark Sanchez Fox NFL
analyst former NFL and USC quarterback